Wow what is design I don't know if I'm
I don't know if I'm gonna take a pass at
answering that let's see design is not a
discipline to me it's an approach or a
methodology power of design of thinking
can be applied in all sorts of areas
that we don't traditionally think of as
designed
but ontology is a creative design studio
and an engineering and robotics together
what we do here is the result of a very
unique culture where we intertwine both
the artist and the engineer it becomes a
very powerful thing to generate
innovative creative experience ideas
that the world has never seen before
we've done a lot of commercial work
without a lot of work in film we were
involved in film gravity was our robots
they were responsible for the motion
control onset that led to some very
innovative to their start a few
approaches we do build a lot of things
here we don't build these robots that
you've seen behind me these are six axes
industrial arm manufacturing robots that
we are constantly asking to do things
that they were never designed to do
working in a place like this is
inherently challenging because the focus
of your job is to imagine things that
are not really possible and then find
ways to bring them into reality